[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 la Reina Isabel II
era conocida por su discreción pero
fuera monarca que más inspiró a los
artistas y los ejemplos que simbolizan
su transformación en un icono pop son
numerosos los Beatles le dedicaron las
canciones icónicas que son formales
y del lado del arte gráfico que así mil
retratos de la reina están en la
colección de la National gallery de
Londres ha sido pintada por grandes
nombres como Francis bacon Chris levin
and the water y las fotos tomadas por
Cecilia de su coronación en 1953
causaron una gran impresión pero fue su
representación en la película de Stephen
frizz en 2006 que marcó un punto de
inflexión en cuanto a su imagen ante el
público por aparecer como una figura más
accesible y emotiva la fue un éxito
arrollador en gran parte Gracias a la
actuación de El admiran que interpretó a
la reina durante el festival de Cana del
año pasado nuestros colegas de la cadena
en inglés hablaron con ella de su
preparación para este papel
hay para este papel estudia la reina
antes de que supiera que iba a ser reina
creo que la reina Es como un submarino
un submarino ya sabes que navega con
todas las facetas de su personalidad
sus pensamientos sus miedos sus
inseguridades sus amores sus obsesiones
todas las cosas que la componen
y está la reina que vemos que es como el
periscopio sobre el agua y que mira
alrededor
y lo que nosotros vemos es el periscopio
no vemos el submarino Me gustaría ver
algo del submarino
una película que allanó el camino para
la serie de Netflix que hizo subir la
popularidad de la corona
Esta obra sigue a la reina desde sus
días como ojo en princesas un matrimonio
su coronación hasta hoy en día con tres
actrices diferentes según las épocas y
una quinta temporada que se estrenará en
noviembre se trata por supuesto de
representación ficticias pero si quieren
acercarse más a la villa Real de la
monarca el reciente documental Elizabeth
Butcher impacts de Roger mitchell les
ofrece una celebración lúdica y
relevante de Isabel segunda solamente
con imágenes de archivos
[Música]
otros dos fallecimientos marcaron el
mundo de la cultura esta semana
Empezando por el retratista clave de las
calles de Nueva York París y Roma
William Klein El fotógrafo
estadounidense afincado en Francia murió
el 17 de septiembre
96 años durante su larga carrera William
clan revolucionó la fotografía de moda y
urbana con imágenes impactantes de la
emoción y la violencia de la ciudad sus
instantáneas lo hicieron famoso por
parecer tomadas que así por casualidad
es considerado uno de los artistas más
influyentes del siglo 20 y del lado del
Séptimo arte el director Franco suizo
Johnny falleció a los 91 años el 13 de
septiembre
cineasta provocador y políticos
que dinamizó los códigos
cinematográficos de la época para soplar
un viento de libertad y hacer entrar la
vida real a las películas
surfismografía incluye más de 100 cintas
como director en casi 60 años de carrera
con su muerte se cierra un capítulo de
La historia del cine
en otras cinematográficas el festival de
Venecia en Italia otorgó su prestigioso
León de oro a toda la belleza y la
sangre un documental de la
estadounidense Laura por atrás que
denuncia la tragedia de los opiáceos y
el escándalo en Estados Unidos por
alimentar deliberadamente la dependencia
a las drogas y las directoras francesa
Alice Job se llevó el segundo galardón
más importante por santomec un filme
sobre la maternidad basado en hechos
reales un juicio por infanticidio
[Aplausos]
en Estados Unidos dos obras se
repartieron los honores en los Amy
Awards el equivalente a los Oscar de la
televisión estadounidense la
gigantescation de hbo ganó el premio a
la mejor serie dramática mientras que la
surcoreanas y su historia en el certamen
con el premio al mejor actor para su
protagonista Li Yuya la primera vez para
un artista que actúa en un idioma
distinto del inglés
[Música]
vamos a hablar ahora de los estrenos
musicales de la semana primero con los
mejores amigos de la banda de rock
francesa Phoenix 25 años de carrera y un
séptimo álbum que saldrá en noviembre
alfasulún que grabaron de noche en una
ala del louvre en el Museo de artes
decorativas
[Música]
y por su parte de la Estrella Argentina
María Becerra estrenó automático un tema
donde rinde homenaje a reggaeton de la
vieja escuela
[Música]
como se siente si rebotan los neumáticos
Nos despedimos con la colaboración Entre
Dos exitosos artistas africanos pato Don
quindian Nigeria y Diamond planets de
tanzania Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en Francia 24.com
[Aplausos]
[Música]